We looked at these images in the last lecture.
We started off with one image and then I also showed you another one.
This one.
In both of these images, the same two subjects just taken from
a different viewpoint and, of course, also different focal length.
In this image, I'd basically taken the picture with a smaller focal length and
here, of course, with a larger focal length.
Basically, the two subjects were at different distances.
The reason for us to look at these two images was because I'm interested in
showing you that by changing the focal length, allows us to move back and
still capture the same scene and by changing the viewpoint,
we can change the perspective of the scene.
For example, here, these two characters look pretty much sitting next to
each other even though they are almost a meter and a half away.